typhoon ghani hit the province of albay
for only a few hours
but the devastation it left behind is
beyond
comprehension this is the coastal
community of tiwi
it was once a busy fishing village of
more than a thousand families
this is all what's left of it now
more than 90 percent of the homes here
have been destroyed
it took nursey and romeo benedict to 15
years to build their home
the only reminder of it now is this
nursey says the water was up to their
necks and they had to wade through rough
waves
to climb onto a wall with their children
but
i was so afraid so afraid for my
children perhaps someone out there may
care to help us
we are in need of food and blankets we
will be grateful for whatever we receive
my six-year-old grandson said papa
please
i am cold and afraid please let's leave
this place now
he was clearly scared
everywhere you turn there is destruction
images that give a glimpse of the
harrowing experience
that people here went through even for a
region often battered by natural
disasters
the devastation here is clearly
unprecedented
this is a community deeply traumatized
by typhungoni
and people here tell us they are
desperate now
they're hungry and homeless typhoon goni
was the most
powerful storm to hip this year it made
landfall in the beakle region early on
sunday morning
leaving a trail of destruction
more than a million people may need help
maxine cal is preparing dinner this pot
of soup will have to feed three families
tonight
tomorrow's meal she says may not come at
all
survivors salvage whatever they can
during the day
and that night they huddled to sleep on
the same ground
where their homes once stood keeping
their children close
they say they were poor but they always
had what they needed
but tyfungoni has taken everything away
jamela allendogan al-jazeera tiwi albay
in the southern luzon region of the
philippines